all right Lords of gaming dotnet I'm a
podcast we are in the building Crash
Team Racing y'all this is one of the
highly anticipated Kart games we got
MJ's the boss we got lost out on a
camera it's gonna be a ball right now we
got like eight players going down car
team racing we're gonna see how this
compares to the legendary Mario Kart
Chucky the controls controls about me
all right all right all right you got 10
seconds to select eraser buddy check out
these frame rates one of the questions
in the realm was uh was gonna do sixty
or thirty we should be able to tell very
fast
please surprise honestly if it's not
sixty so we're gonna see what's going on
we got eight people all linked up here
in the Sony booth had to have a lot of
action not intensity
I'm Jay you ready Adam do we do
the boss is engaged the boss let's go
musics Baba all right all right let's go
animation is good you see right now also
we got to keep in mind too with far is
own like how Mario Kart has the
different CC classes this might not be
the fastest CC class so I don't want to
make a judgment get on framerate because
you know as you go go up in our speed
classes the game could probably move
faster right now so I looking like 30
but how many impression is probably good
into 60 is that a faster class all of
these barrels it's crazy all right
Oh what about very vibrating games very
vibrant
[Music]
boss hold down that first baby he's
holding always Bally's so it's a battle
so I get his rear view got alligators on
the Left hmm Godspeed bulls nice there
we go oh you got a target on your back
and he put up the shield awesome so
little countermeasure
one of those magic boxes there we go TNT
oh oh you got to be really strategic
with that's crazy they got a lot of
obstacles going on see if we can catch
that first-place guy the boss is on him
right now the boss is on him shooting
out bombs low premature toe pulling that
second place down trying to get first
place though there we go there we go
through the bumps I just it is you put
the pressure on putting praise you got
one more oh it would have been nice
right there it would have been nice
right there shot early but it's cool
final lap still got a shot
we need one slip-up or we need one bomb
you see what we get
roll the dice roll the dice no way I'm
he's don't man we got the green juice I
don't know what the green juice do but
we're gonna see green juice all right up
top okay
I'm jeanna boss it's back and forth oh
we got live we got late you're still in
first oh oh oh we got sabotage we got
sabotage all type of shenanigans all
type of shenanigans son he got hit it's
still going down so close so close
damn they sabotaging our boy always
falling it's boys not looking good right
now spooky right now it's real spooky or
the less so good oh no oh no it's really
spooky right now we went from six from
second to six damn back to fifth oh man
my boys falling apart
falling apart they doing all excitement
tricks on them whoa people falling by
the wayside back up to fourth trying to
finish strong let's get that three
let's get that three oh come on oh man
they are doing all types of sabotage in
the MJ right now it's not looking good
they point 32 boys playing 30 oh yeah
listen first the fifth had a good run
out of control feeling out of control
this didn't feel like very exactly like
different mechanics probably so look
like we're getting back to the lobby see
if they give us enough with anything
I'll give us a novel let's see get a
rematch on that all right so look we
gotta let it slide
get the power sliding on the l1 r1 all
right so we're gonna try that next time
see how that go crash team racing y'all
all right here we go here we go lap two
right up
all right here we go selecting our
characters yeah there we go it's like og
take the og come on there we go mmm I
wonder if the cars have different
attributes was this all a visual ding
yeah that one's kind of pimp I like that
one there we go buddy everybody's
waiting already up
electron a venir
nice everybody's ready DUP let's get the
competition let's see what we going up
against then it's the competition right
there we learn how to do the power slide
we ready this time we ready
all right bombs away you can shoot the
bowling ball
folding left down press circle next time
saving wouldn't want it straight away
did you shoot him while he was throwing
a curve because you could have got that
door there we go
it's looking like it's straight out of
crack now it's book crackdown King races
there we go let's go baby
no booze all right even it's kind of
even everybody's intense right now even
are they stealing the boxes it's still
in the boxes still in feet fifth we
right in position right oh we getting
lapped Oh still early right in position
and you don't need to panic just get one
of them boxes there we go all right all
right we got the wild mask I don't know
what this do run into them run into the
net look like you can run into so much
yeah there we go there we go let's get
real physical with you
let's get physical there's a jump for
that part all right let's get one of
these ramps
let's get one of these ramps nice there
we go okay for now fourth place back in
the fifth
nice oh there we go
nice good snatch his snatch there we go
there go two bombs it's gonna break this
get him right right in front of am there
we go he out of hits let's go bomb up
default oh they're playing dirty every
time you do dirt they do dirt bag this
game this game is all about shenanigans
and pissing people this is the games
they'll be ruining friendships no family
fights
oh man that's what you love about these
these type of car racing games let's go
we got it CNC shop in a box
just go back to fifth we got to start
making traction yeah it looks really
good it looks really good yeah grab some
really claim doing this power slide all
right all right
oh look so much but it's all good there
we go all people are messing up
what is this timer thing what is that
about
Wow hey just playing dirty are we all
the way back but it's not looking good
y'all not over yet we got one more lap I
don't know if I got that faith yet but
we're gonna see the up to six you got to
get the momentum though you gotta get
some momentum is that tracking nice okay
got you one more lap we got to start
gaining ground and it's not looking good
out here y'all and we fall in order look
it's all or we just fallen apart right
now we fall apart Metro Metro game Oh
when it rains it pours
oh boy it is pouring we're holding on
that eighth spot baby we got that we
better be careful we don't get lapped
lap territory what the fruits do yes
I'm assuming the fruits got to be like a
Mario Kart mechanic where the more you
have the the faster your overall speed
is that's what I'm assuming at least
let's finish strong and finish off but
it's oh we got to get one spot try to
get one spot back even though we see
nobody
[Laughter]
they need some catch-up mechanics for
the eighth all good all good we learn in
the course right now we learn it
boom mmm misters fire extinguish about
its that about I don't know I don't even
know what to tell you but I don't even
know tell you what that one yeah they
say you gonna hold this Elle on 8th and
they certainly abusing the 8th place guy
with autotargeting they got no love now
this is where I did hope that there
would be catching I think like Mario
Cart does a good job of having catch-up
mechanics you yeah you just ran right
into it you was magnetic to that bottle
tiki mask all right yeah they need like
a star you need your booze yeah that's
what I'm noticing it's like they this is
if you lose you lose then you will not
be coming back they won't be messing
with the algorithm to try to give you
stuff to come back at least in this
match
but I think some hardcore guys are some
might prefer that you know some people
just like hey if I'm better than you I'm
how I'll Drive and I'm outs killing you
then there shouldn't be any type of
stuff like that yeah I like the lava so
we do the rocky rocket to get it ain't
no catch-up mechanic going down at all
day to day day just do not care they
like you were a few gonna hold a safe
and we're not giving you no ketchup
mechanics like Mario Kart you're gonna
learn the course oh we close at least we
get lapto least we can get loud is that
Louis off in the building north/south
check it out or something I am not
well-versed at play-by-play commentary
son of my video apart from my interviews
[Music]
listen it was too late two races we went
in seventh and we went in eighth we held
the back end down the back end was lit
grab which is good crash team racing
y'all get your fix man